built in 1931 to house two famous silent
movie stars the walking box Ranch has a
rich history in Nevada it's been dormant
for nearly a decade until now thanks to
students from unlv's public history
program they will host Public tours at
the ranch this weekend featuring many
interactive elements having to do with
the house the ranch and the famous
actors that live there Clara Beau and
Rex Bell their son Rex Bell Jr shared
with us the origin of the ranch's name
at one time that was called The Box k
he was up on outside
with the legs coming this way which
makes it a k
and Dad just flipped it over and made it
the walking box and if Rex Bell Jr rings
a bell you may remember him as a Clark
County D.A in the late 70s and 80s the
property and Searchlight still houses
nearly a hundred-year-old Furniture
decor and other items such as Clara's
makeup case and Rex's uh old cowboy hats
much of this can be seen on the tours
being put on by unlv's history program
taking place tomorrow from 2 P.M to 5
p.m you can register by visiting our
website 8newsnow.com